We're interested in
the concept of emergence.
So emergence is
where functions emerge
that are not evident
in the individual parts.
So if we think about emergence in
biological systems
the classical swarms
of birds flying,
or fish schooling.
No one really understands how those individual
entities coordinate their actions, but this
has huge implications also for medicine.
So how do cells turn into tissues, tissues
organs, and organs organisms?
And in fact what's really exciting about the
CIFAR program that is unusual and unique across
the world is we're also looking at how one
can engineer these systems so this has implications
for autonomous vehicles.
So now you know, we're envisioning a future
state where a number of different autonomous
vehicles interact with each other and we want
to avoid unexpected consequences of that interaction
as well as control and optimize their function
and we think there's real commonalities between
individual cells, individual organisms, and
now individual machines especially when those
machines are started to be endowed with autonomous
properties such as happens with AI and other systems.
We think that the opportunity of act - of
understanding human-machine interfaces from
a cellular transplantation perspective right
through to prosthetics and finally humans
interacting with autonomous vehicles all depend
upon understanding two-way communication
between devices and humans broadly interpreted.
And so that will enable all kinds of new applications
in those areas as well.
These problems have no international boundaries.
You know, we seek out and have brought together
the best people in the world around this problem
whether they're in Canada, Germany, the US,
or Japan and that really is something that
otherwise is tough to get the attention of
these people, and CIFAR because of its reputation,
because of its infrastructure is allowing
us to do that so that's a very exciting aspect.
[Music]